what I'm going to need you to do with me
is draw two cyclists okay one of them is
going to be a cyclist that's motley
noble somebody's rather like this you
should write a little bit 50 children
have stuff on here in a second so this
is a cyclist and they are on a flat
surface okay so let's analyze the forces
that are happening here and just as they
are a little point this is going to be a
lot easier if we consider this from the
cyclists frame of reference okay now I
know that's not know sure they're
actually accelerating because they are
turning of course but the forces that
will be able to consider are much more
easy to see if you think about it from
the cypress point of view okay so over
here I already considered some forces
right how many of them are still
relevant here how many are still
relevant all three right let's have a
look at them let's start with say the
gravity force ok now the gravity force
the weight force i should say is here
now what's lovely about this i'm
actually going to consider the forces
acting at different points along the
actual dimensions of my cyclist and bike
okay so here's um oops sorry that's
that's not right mg he's actually acting
on the center of mass right this is what
we were discussing before of line in
trying to pick a point for where should
we can see that for it ok so the center
of mass is going to be somewhere around
here so there's MJ that's good ok what
are the vertical forces do we have here
the normal because the ground is still
flat right so from here up that way I've
got the normal force now looking at
these two points okay all right there
isn't fixed either of them the points
about which rotation would happen if it
were to happen look look carefully
what's right here is there an over right
now I think it is the point of contact
beth here on the ground the point one
picked earlier ok if we are going to
incline
we're going to retain just like that
cyclist over there we're going to
incline like this right this point is
going to stay put the tie is going to
stay on the ground and the rest of our
body is what tilts back and forth so
this is kind of like our fixed point
here ok now we imagine our turn going to
that side of the board so there is a
friction force isn't it there's a
lateral force so let's draw it going off
here there's our lateral force now that
was all fine this is in an inertial
frame of reference omit here there is
one force we haven't accounted for if
you're thinking about the cyclist point
of view what forces it ok I'm thinking
about it from what's changed is not
whether my thinking about how how big it
is in terms of life like this is still
it's still only one dimensional so it's
actually not gonna experience any it
doesn't take up any area ok what I think
about is if I'm the cyclist and I'm
turning right think about those up
figure out the wall of death guys right
what they are experiencing is a
fictitious force away from the center of
the tone does that make sense their
experience here i'm going to call it C
for centrifugal force it's fictitious
right but in the frame of reference it
is they can feel that sensation ok
alright so I've got all these forces now
in mine on leading cyclist maybe you're
right that at the top yeah psychosis
turned that way which is why the
friction force is going that way ladder
yes in Trivial centrifugal force not
sick centripetal force goes to the set
up centripetal force and centrifugal
force is going on waivers and it's
fictitious if the lateral forces the
friction force yep then shouldn't
incentive for the lateral force yes
that's right it's because you're turning
your wheel you're turning your wheel so
it's the traction of the wheels which
has friction which actually makes you
negotiate the term so the friction is
actually does that make sense you have
to Tom Tommy oh ok now how does look for
a second just like with our whiteboard
markers before I'm gonna ask you two
questions first I want to talk about the
linear forces what is the net linear
force net linear force is zero right you
can see balance balance balance balance
or group but now that I have this
category of talk in mind now I want to
think about one two three four forces
and I want to think about the talk force
that is exerted ok let's start from the
ground ok these guys here how much talk
to nazar a lateral force and the normal
how much talk do they exert and the
answer is they don't exert any because
they are at the point of rotation they
are like putting a force no matter which
way you are ok which way you're facing
if you're pointing at the action point
of rotation you're not going to make
this whole thing spin around at all ok
so these guys may contribute no talk so
far so good what about this one without
the weight force what talk does it exert
its are still nothing right because you
can only tilt this way or that way and
this was going down right down through
toward the point of rotation so it
doesn't exert talk Eva there's only one
force that exhaust talk and it's this
guy right this guy over here so it is
going in what direction it's going this
way so I guess I would call that edgy
clockwise is there anything to balance
this talk nope so the cyclist falls over
ok they are turning their wheel and not
leaning they're going to fall and
paradoxically figure to fall out of the
turn in for a double turn ok so this is
the non leaning cyclist and it is not
absolutely with this is not a stable
situation so now let's your are leaning
Cyprus and see what changes
we're still going to have the ground
which is flat but now we're going to
have to draw our cyclist off an angle
into the turn okay so I'm going to draw
like so got my cyclist now I'm going to
put my forces on one at a time again
going to start from the ground okay
these forces here valera force and the
normal force what's changed in terms of
where they're facing and how much talk
that they exist what's changed nothing
has changed nothing is changing right
here are right the lateral force is
still going the same way in the same
amount and the normal force is still
perpendicular to the ground and they're
still at the point of rotation so not
exerting any talk okay these two guys
over here right up at the center of
gravity the center of gravity which
means the centrifugal force going it's
still going towards the outside of the
turn it's still going this way right
it's still exerting a talk in the
anti-clockwise direction so maybe I'll
just add that in there
so this is the petitioners force yeah ah
but here is the demand money moment
right the last force that we have here
is the weight force right now what's
happened to the weight force well it's
still vertical right but what's it
directed at now yeah it's not directed
at the point of rotation anymore it's
directed away from that right so this is
mg right but we respect to the cyclist
it is imparting this um miss the way I'm
going to do it I'll do it this way it's
imparted a clockwise torque on the
cyclist which balances out with the
centrifugal force that ad clockwise
torque is happening there and that's why
does she's stable that is why not just
the cycles care but the cyclist must
actually leaned over to not fall over
okay which is kind of weird and Kevin to
do but also super awesome I think that's
really cool understand